بينها وبين الحلم بالدراسه حلم بالعبور
الى البلد المقصود تحاول القبضه الحوثيه
تحطيما عبير المكتري شابه يمنيه من محافظه
تعز ارادت استكمال تحصيلها العلمي في مصر
بعد حصولها على منحه دراسه هناك
لكن مليشيات الحوثي ابتسمح لها بذلك ربما
اليقينها بوهان رصاصها امام قوه رصاص قلم
بين انامل عبير
فلاحقتها وغلقت الابواب امامها فلم يعد
بامكانها المغادره لا جوا عبر مطار صنعاء
ولا برا باتجاه مطار عدن
لله
تم منعه من السفر من قبل الحوثيين في مطار
صنعاء
فقلت اسافر بدل ما اسافر من مطار صنعاء
اسافر من مطار عدن
وانا بطريقي لعدم تم نعيم مره ثانيه من
قبل الحوثيين
القصه هي عبير ومسيلاتها القصه هي المراه
اليمنيه فالاكبر القصه شعب مردهن بقبضه
ميليشيا تجبرت بالسلاح فسامحت لمواليها
ومنعت عن الاخرين وما من سبيل سوى الكلمه
عبر الكتابه وفضح هذه الاساليب واستنكارها
او عبر التواصل مع المجتمع الدولي في حاله
انه يستطيع الضغط على هذه الميليشيات عبير
مثالها كمثل شابه افغانيه او صدى الطالبان
ابواب الجامعات والمدارس دونها لان امراه
متعلمه ستنشئ جيلا سيهرق بوعيه حاكمه
حوثيا كان ام من طالبا ام اخرين يم نجلاء
العربيه